the first impeachment witness appearing
on capitol hill today
it comes as president trump and joe
biden continue to attack each other over
ukraine
here's the latest former special envoy
to ukraine kurt volcker
testifying behind closed doors meanwhile
house intelligence chair
adam schiff saying he's facing new
scrutiny
after it was revealed that whistleblower
the whistleblower had contact with the
house intelligence committee
before filing the complaint now here is
the president's latest attack on schiff
and biden chip has now been proven to be
a liar we've known it for three years
because they've been trying to impeach
for three years uh he's a lot he's a
stone cold liar
if they were honest about it that sought
a major investigation into the biden
and by the way likewise china
should start an investigation into the
biden
because what happened to china is just
about as bad as what happened
with with ukraine
biden is fighting back against trump's
attacks but raising new questions by
admitting he talked to his son about
ukraine
mr trump and his hatchet and the special
interest funding his attacks against me
i'm not going anywhere you're not going
to destroy me
you're not going to destroy my family i
talked to my son uh
i we've we've communicated he lives out
in california
we communicated a couple times but look
there is zero zero zero zero evidence
of any assertion being made and other
democrats are going after trump as well
claiming
the president is scared of impeachment
i think the president knows the argument
that can be made against him
and he's scared he also is actually
obviously
motivated by fear clearly he's afraid
for the public to see
either one of those things he's afraid
of just how
badly he may be beaten in november
dana i was you know struck that the
president
you know people saying oh you shouldn't
have called and talked to the ukrainian
president about getting dirt on joe
biden today he says just out loud
yeah china i'd like you to go get some
dirt yeah he's saying the quiet part out
loud
um and it's different and i basically
he's saying
okay american people you decide if this
is wrong um
now some democrats will say well there's
a law and the law says you can't do this
um but then president trump is saying
well is there there's laws against
corruption as well
and so he's just basically putting it
out there i don't think he's afraid um i
think that's a talking point
you can always tell when the bat phone
bat signal has gone out with the word
now everybody say the word afraid today
and you'll get a gold star in your chart
at the end of the day
um the thing about schiff having the the
whistleblower complaint before it does
i think for nancy pelosi her deputizing
him to be
basically the spokesperson on this is
not
a clear-cut win for her because he one
made up
the parody of the phone call that he led
the serious hearing with is just keeps
coming up over and over again
and then there's this question of why
weren't you completely forthcoming now
i think they have a good point that they
could say well the white house had the
heads up about the whistleblower account
because the cia had gone to the white
house lawyers first of all before they
went to the justice department
so that gets a little bit more
complicated but i think schiff as a
spokesperson
for this it's not necessarily great for
nancy pelosi but
i don't think she has any other good
options she's probably going to have to
drive this train herself
all right so jesse uh the question that
dana raises i think is the one on a lot
of people's mind so
is this wrong or is it illegal we know
today
that the chairman chairwoman i should
say of the federal election commission
ellen weintraub said retweeted
that you can't do this that it's illegal
to ask another country for help
anything of value in terms of political
getting dirt on a political opponent
our senior judicial analyst judge
napolitano
he he wrote he said you know just the
summary of the phone call
uh with the president zelinski of
ukraine shows and i'm quoting here
criminal and impeachable
behavior i respectfully disagree with
judge napolitano
and i would like to hold up another
treaty yes
this is the treaty we have signed in
2000 with
china for corruption and criminal things
that we can ask them about and we can
pull documents from
and just because joe biden happens to be
running against the president
doesn't make him above the law okay he
could drop out tomorrow and then
trump could ask china get out of here
you're saying
the u.s government and the chinese
government and the ukrainian government
can't ask questions about the biden
family because he's a politician
it's crazy so i believe that trumps any
sort of fec violation
also it boils down to this trump is
draining the swamp and that's what the
democrats want him impeach for
and they care more about him fingering
their corruption than the actual corrupt
acts themselves
and he's going to swing for the fences
like you said he's going to double down
and do this right out in the sunlight
and he's going to say why are you trying
to impeach me
let the americans vote on this now the
chinese thing
also uncovered some more interesting
facts about hunter
because hunter is in business with john
kerry's son-in-law
a heinz and what did they do in 2017.
they cut a deal with a chinese communist
back company
for 600 million dollars for an
automobile
firm and you know what that chinese bat
company had done a few years before
stolen american technology and used it
on their stealth fighter jets
and you know who let the deal go through
john kerry
when he was secretary of state also
while joe biden was vice president
to say that that is zero evidence of
corruption
you put that to the american people and
you think they're gonna say oh yeah
nothing to see here that's crazy and
there's a long
laundry list of biden family members for
sale if you look at hunter
if you look at his brother his 1.5
billion
deal in iraq while joe was the point man
for iraq
so the whole thing's crazy and if you
look at what hillary clinton was
when she was running for senate in 2000
in new york
bill clinton pardoned all those puerto
rican terrorists
so she could get the puerto rican vote
or in 1999 when rudy was mayor here and
he was considering running for senate
against hillary clinton
bill clinton sent the feds to go
investigate rudy and the nypd
so there's no corruption there or how
about hillary when she's secretary of
state
or running for president her
foundation's getting
tens of millions of dollars from morocco
saudi arabia
that's not foreign interference in the
election come on well
okay i those democrats not a commercial
break
hey katie the news of the day that we
can also point to is
kurt volcker the former special envoy to
the ukraine
who was mentioned in the whistleblower
complaint going up to capitol hill
and what we have heard is that he
testified that he warned
rudy giuliani not to believe what he was
hearing from
various people in the ukraine who had
involvement with corruption
prosecution he said these people aren't
trustworthy what do you make of that
i think it's hard to make a decision
about testimony that is done behind
closed doors because
it's going to be politicized especially
by democrats who are running the show on
this impeachment inquiry which is like
impeachment but not impeachment because
it doesn't have the legal backing of
impeachment but they can go back to
their left base and say that
they're calling people in front of
congress to get information and then
they can leak out selectively what they
want to because it's not in front of the
public so they can make their own
decisions
so i'm going to hold off on my judgment
of that
i do want to say that jesse you should
do a one more thing that is
treaties with waters go around the world
and tell us about new treaties that a
big thick one right
but this is bad for joe biden for two
reasons the first reason is that it is
bringing attention to
these accusations that have been written
up in mainstream media for over a year
the new yorker the new york times about
hunter biden's dealings
it brings up the issue of corruption and
joe biden now has been inconsistent in
his account
of his talks with his son so just now in
that clip he says
i is zero zero zero evidence of any
corruption or wrongdoing
well when you say zero zero zero you
better be correct because when something
comes up in the future
especially in a campaign you're going to
get nailed on it either by trump
or all the other democrats running in
the party and elizabeth warren is now
i think going to be the front-runner
pretty soon when it comes to leaping
over
joe biden she hasn't really jumped onto
this because she's allowing joe biden to
get over this with trump
but you know joe joe biden might not
even be the nominee so what's the
question then
do the investigations continue forward
if warren wins we'll have to see
or warn the primary what do you think
about what dana said was the talking
point of the day for the democrats
scared afraid mr trump afraid they
should be scared look
i hate complaining about this job we
have a great job we get paid to talk
about stuff
but this story just bugs the crap out of
me because i know it's so fake
this is a political story masquerading
as a moral social story right
it's true it's an attempt to turn
hearsay into heresy
it's just a congenial phone call but
it's become something so big
and we have to pretend every day when we
come here we have to pretend as we
report this stuff
that to you we believe that it's really
really important when for us
it's just a carousel that we got to hop
on and then hop off at the end of the
day
thank god for hunter biden because this
is just so much easier to understand
when he becomes the focus the american
viewer when they're at home they don't
care about the phone call
they they can look at the transcript and
see what it is but everybody
understands nepotism everybody
understands the
pampered jackass offspring who did
nothing productive with his life and
just
fed off his daddy's name everybody knows
that guy
everybody can't stand him and he's the
hood ornament
of the swamp jalopy right then and there
he is he is
everything that is bad and then the best
part is the media complaining not
complaining but
concerned about trump's anger yesterday
oh he seemed so upset
that's like lighting firecrackers and
complaining about the noise
that's like going to a fish restaurant
and going you know this tastes
fishy dude you created this mess you've
been spending three years trying to get
the bear to snap you got him to snap
i also noticed how happy the media is
that rachel maddow
finally you know has a story right
because for the last six months
it's been really sad on her show the
numbers are down but now she's gone
she's on the view
there's articles about her it's like
she's like uh
it's like her homecoming it's just like
a homecoming dance and a bat mitzvah
to be put together uh and
is that what it's called i'm a catholic
but i've never seen them i've never seen
a media work so hard with so little
the same media that chuckled over
benghazi in which four people died
are now screaming about a phone call
they're screaming about a phone call how
can they do that with a straight face
anyway i hate talking about it but for
some reason i was able to do it for two
minutes
by the way though what about what about
like ivanka and her shoe deal
with the chinese it's an interesting
question because all hundred
all of uh trump's kids actually work
what does hunter yeah know about finance
oh i can see
hip hop all right